Here's our mapper code. Let's look at it line by
line. We're going to loop around standard input, which gives
us a line at a time. Of course, the line
will have a new line character so let's strip that off,
plus any other white space around the line. Since our
line is tab delimited, let's split untab at the same
time. This gives us an array, called data. So now
we'll take the array, data, and assign it into individual variables
for date, time, store, item, cost, and payment. Lastly, we'll
print the items we care about, which is store and cost.
As you use Hadoop more and more, you'll discover that the
more data you have, the more likely you are to encounter
weirdness in the data. Lines could be malformed. There could
be strange log messages in the data, and many other cases
that you might not even imagine. So we should make sure
that no matter what kind of data we get, the mapper
can continue working. You don't want to be halfway through a two
terabyte job when it dies. So let's go back and add
some defensive programming, to make sure things don't break, even if
you get a strange line in the middle of your data.